- [Kelly] Your shoes are amazing.
Your pearls.
- All of it.
- Ah, well meet Bowie, I mean, Rachel.
- So nice to meet you, I'm
a big fan of both of you.
- Oh, thank you.
Give me your baby.
- Give me your- (Kelly laughs)
I know it's such a creepy storyline.
- I re-watched that song in preparation.
It's just him stealing a baby.
Go on, this is your segment.
- Yeah,
it is a weird thing,
but I'm still into it.
So, are there any particular like looks
from the 80s that you miss or loved?
- I miss the big hair and
the big shoulder pads.
- Oh! Brought to you by, what?
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- I love a shoulder pad.
- I do too, because I mean
kind of the proportion thing.
- [Kelly] You knew it.
- It works for ya.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The big hair, you know,
closer to God. All of it.
- Amen.
So, your new show is all about pop culture
collections right?
- Right.
- [Kelly] So, what got you into this show?
It's interesting.
- You know, I had filmed a
little pilot with my daughter
and the producer, that didn't go,
but the producers called me and said,
"We've got this show.
You kind of travel around,
meeting people with great collections."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I had just become a life coach,
and so I'm really fascinated by people,
especially really people that
are kind of on the fringe
of you know, living in reality,
not that I know...
- On the fringe!
Look at-- (Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- What do you mean?
Voodoo, you do.
So I love that they're on the line.
They're walking a very narrow line.
- They are, but they're not.
I mean people often ask me,
"Are these people hoarders?"
And they're not,
because they're very intentional
and they know their passion,
they know their purpose
and they are absolutely
100% committed to it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it 99% of the
time has something to do
with trying to hang on to
something from their childhood.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's like nostalgia.
- And I think it's why that,
you know, why we're having 80s week.
- Yeah.
- It's why it's on MeTV.
- It's why not?
- We all want to have
you know a simpler, pure, sweeter time,
even if it's just 30 minutes.
- Amen. It's been a complicated few years.
So did you collect anything growing up
other than crystal balls?
- I weirdly I collected snow globes.
- [Kelly] Oh, so it's
all coming full circle.
- Which is why this is quite apt.
- That's amazing. Wait, snow globes, like,
I used to be obsessed with
those when I was little.
- Everywhere I went I would
get a different snow globe,
and I still have one that my
friend sent me from New York
because he saw a bunch of
cool Broadway shows in 2004.
And then I have a snow globe
that celebrated the year 2000,
that if you play it, it
still plays Auld Lang Syne,
and it has like a cheap little hat
and bottle of champagne in the center.
I'm just gonna keep doing this.
- It would've been an
amazing snow globe, though,
remember when everybody thought everyone
was gonna die in 2000?
It would've been funny if it just was like
a self-destructing snow globe.
- If it's just an
apocalyptic snow globe? Man.
- Would've been a missed opportunity.
- And then it does nothing, though,
because that's what happened at Y2K.
It did nothing.
- I know!
Everybody was so, they were like,
everybody was storing rice.
I'm like, okay.
But I mean, it's just
like a weird... anyway.
And then toilet paper, when COVID hit.
I'm like, really?
Like, out of all the things
you could be collecting
in case (beep) hits the fan?
I mean, I guess you have
toilet paper for it.
- Literally.
- [Lisa] There you go.
- Yeah, and I was just like,
I don't understand why
it was toilet paper.
Anyway, I'm letting go of it, obviously.
So you're a grandmother now.
So is that way more fun than being a mom,
'cause it's just kind of cooler?
- It is so much more
fun for so many reasons.
- [Kelly] Let me hear about that.
- [Lisa] I babysit my
grandkids every Monday, yes.
- [Kelly] Ahh, look at that little nugget.
- [Lisa] I know. Echo and Eisley.
- Echo?
- Echo.
- That is so cool.
- Yeah, they're cool kids.
Like, I have cool kids and cool grandkids.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- I love it, yes.
- It's just so, I always
hear everybody talking about
how that's, like, their
favorite thing to be a grandma.
What do they call you?
- They call me Coco Mama.
- [Kelly] What?
- Yes. Yes.
- Do you give 'em hot cocoa a lot or?
- No, no. I mean, this is a
family show, right? So, okay.
- Yes. Go for it.
- Well they can't, they'll
never be allowed to watch
this episode until they're teenagers
because the name Coco Mama came
because when their parents got engaged,
they got engaged in Paris.
So I'd taken my adult kids.
We went backpacking across
Europe, stayed in hostels.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So we stopped in Amsterdam.
- Oh, yes.
- And we stayed at a
hostel called Coco Mama.
You know, we loved it, but
we went to a coffee shop.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And they're all adults.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we decided when in Amsterdam.
- You know?
- Yeah.
- Well, we did the newbie doobie mistake.
- [Kelly] It hits you hard.
- And we thought, "Well
this isn't doing anything,
let's have another slice."
- Yeah. Oh, no. Oh my God. Oh.
- Oh yeah.
So we're going through the streets
when it hits me and I'm thinking,
"Okay, those men over there
are going to harvest our organs."
- And everyone's on bikes, riding around
and you're like dodging 'em.
- Oh, yes.
No, I'm stopping them, because I'm saying,
I'm stopping people on
the street and saying,
"We're from America. We
just had some space cake.
I am responsible for these
children. I am not responsible.
Call an ambulance, call a taxi, whatever."
- Call God.
- "Get us to Coco Mama."
My son-in-law was
sobered up enough to say,
"Mrs. Cauble," 'cause that's
what he called me then,
before they got married,
"I'll get you back to Coco Mama."
So two days later, we were
in Paris, they got engaged.
And I said, "Don't call
me Mrs. Cauble anymore,
You don't have to call
me mom, but you know,
find something else to call me."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he said, "I'm gonna
call you Coco Mama."
- Because you think that
you probably said it once,
but you probably said it a billion times.
- A billion times.
- [Kelly] Coco Mama!